you have one goal which is to stop Hamas
quote unquote but you are
doing imagine living for decades under
an open air prison where everything you
do is controlled from what you eat to
what you drink brothers and sisters
please donate as we have come together
one um to get the necessary Aid needed
the Palestine and Gaza keep them in your
duas but specifically brother and
sisters give from what you love inshah
and love for your brothers and sisters
what you love for yourself donate now in
whatever you can and allow us to reach
the aid with one um to our brothers and
sisters in Palestine one day Palestine
will be
free brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well insh it
is so vital for us as public figures and
whoever is working in what industry that
we are all vocal it plays a super super
important role for us to tell the story
of the Palestinians with the biased
Western media chunks is one of those
Brothers Who's in the YouTube scene and
in the mainstream media and he is quite
big and it is very important for him to
take this on board as well and which he
has he has spoken about the actual cause
of the Palestinians here is is a video
of him
expressing um how he is against what's
going on with which is normal human
reaction but it is so vital for him to
talk about this no matter what the
consequences are here's the video I have
a problem with people that are killing
innocent innocent kids I understand they
say they they're trying to Target Hamas
um but why are people in the West Bank
dying then there's no Hamas people that
actually are in the West Bank but
there's still numbers uh people of
number of people dying in the West Bank
there's children being arrested there's
kidnapped kid of course there's there's
there's they're stopping water flow
they're stopping food they're stopping
it's like so much things happening and
it's kind of like you have one goal
which is to stop Hamas quote unquote but
you are doing everything you can see
Allah says
in come together with uh for
righteousness and piety and this is
exactly the attitude that it needs to be
you do not need to be a Muslim the
thousands hundreds of thousands and
millions of people around the world a
lot of them are not Muslim but they
understand the plight Allah has put
innately in all of us Mercy compassion
love only somebody who's got a dead
heart could wish death on innocent
people like you've heard from the occupi
side that clearly they're calling these
people's Human animals that all of them
should be
punished collectively and they are
laughing and mocking on Tik Tok the
whole world has seen what kind of
Barbarians and how coldhearted
individuals these people are they do not
care any human for that being who sees a
child killed or blown into pieces would
have their heart move you do not see it
with these Pro Zionist you do not see
with these Zionist so much so we have
Jews in Stanford Hill yes Rabbi Beck and
these individuals who have come come
together which they even see the plight
which you know this is not something
Judaism teaches but rather these Zionist
atheist who do not have a religion who
are nationalists so I want to thank
brother chunks may Allah bless and
preserve him please bro talk about this
issue more often I met your father
actually in um Brent Cross I think it
was Bren cross alhamdulillah it had so
much nice things to say about you and so
did he you know he told me a lot of
stuff may Allah bless you and preserve
you you're an amazing son we all have
our ups and downs but please bro please
try to speak about the Palestinian issue
more we need you to do that all of us
public figures have to step it up
wherever you are because the more we
don't see and people act like DJ khed
who's a Palestinian himself shame on him
I haven't seen a single post this guy's
even deleting comments cuz he's too
occupied with the worldy gains and W if
you or anyone for that matter puts the
money or the wealth like DJ khed before
the pl of these people Allah subhana wa
ta'ala will humiliate you with that
wealth and not only that on because bear
in mind the Palestinian brothers and
sisters can stand in front of Y and say
what did these guys do we need to do our
part please guys like I've always said
number one fix your relationship with
Allah Allah's right is more important
than anybody's for that matter number
that's if you care about the
Palestinians good you should you should
care about Allah's H more how many of us
miss Salah number two boycot products
boycott them yes boycott them number
three sharing in social media post
platforms and making Dua inshah may
Allah subh bless you guys and may Allah
bless our brother chunk chunks please
please Aki be more vocal about it and
carry on talking may Allah bless and
preserve you till next
time